Trimble plebeians at the demonic
intellect of dr. Insano I am here to
conquer this pathetic country starting
with this convention con Bravo I have
hired a henchman what was your name
again
Sister Sister I Igor he's as dumb as a
bag of hammers but he works sheep and so
we're going to conquer this pathetic
nation
one by one by destroying the Nerds who
inhabit this hotel what say you in
Chester a bum you're paying me in
Timmins yes hurry we've arrived time to
conquer this pathetic country or one
that Florio the way they do things in
Canada L is French from 108 Canadian
noise I could use some more choice now
we see they threw advances of science
just like a replica of a light
because he taught at last we meet do you
really think your intellect can match
the demonic mind of dr. insane oh I who
are hunting what to lose you but I'm
taking over this country
therefore it is mine what would tiny
little people do they have to die to
bidness I buried my first test subject
in one of those fancy 26 almost like the
Japanese don't know with my final means
I had a bad case of pullin over one time
I got a lotion where does this go I
won't let why don't I have a person
atomic mass why would you think is it me
I don't know whose it is but it's
definitely not yours oh goodness
Mays plasma 40 watt range snow crap I
got bit by a spider science science is
wonderful
science is what will help me conquer
this nation you will all kneel before me
are you announcing your campaign for
Prime Minister no actually I've learned
that you do not actually elect prime
ministers that appointed
what kind of back pathway is that that's
as crazy as making your money plastic
they don't remember r2d2 and Darth Vader
being the same size I never drop of the
Hutt being on solo tiny them and they
change that all they wanted oh it's the
most horrifying thing that's ever
happened I can't possibly talk about it
unless it comes out on a suburban nights
DVD opening in two weeks to a month
thank you granny
fermentation of course I do
experimentation you do homosexual
experimentation with fans where blonde
wigs that's how I got where I am I'll
get back to you on that are you really -
I have bus tickets do those count if I
can live on the bus okay I think that's
the first thing I saw when I was born
say what you're like I can't possibly be
more you know Stephen - before you take
over Canada might as well learn about
your competition the red panda crime
cabal am I taking this or not hey oh wow
I'll take kids my job some really old
sagging superheroes look at it looks
like they're not quite ready to be
photographed your ring I love doing
Pride and Prejudice oh my god space is
hideous and this big in the past
background for the bass back
horrible supervillain and your head and
said you just functional practically a
bra this happened to me once I took some
pillows for its legal ones that's what
started it too
I think ice from your human spider
experiment let's not mention that again
it didn't end well
I know I know where that Perkins school
girls
because no matter what it is I'll change
the age of consent in this country you
know the girl hair in your palms
oh no this can't be some kind of
artificial moistness
I didn't gave some artificial noises
right now is this the one known as dr.
Holocaust I've heard so much about
yes too much mortality twin brother so I
got evil a voice and everything was
costume than I did it very impressed it
seems I have an opponent in the next
election the game is off
I think it's quaint how you think there
will be an election what why wouldn't
that be there's not gonna be any voting
Insano
I will simply conquer this but dream in
the rest of this miserable world please
I have the support of the people
Chester she wants maybe something to
write it out
which is such a hard surface oh my dad's
I got exact backwards Jean heard you
don't look at all like how I remembered
you looked at you know he's a doctor for
you convert the currency into Insano
dollars nobody's there it's round you
into an icy and articulates it because
they're gonna be bowing to your power
certainly as well you should
and while you're down there time to do
this joke material I know we need to
show up to the rehearsals would you quit
molesting the flesh it's a happy very
bad idea to market jewelry that looks
like fortune cookies yes finances with
what to wait wow I know that's wrong
someone ran over a brownie and he was
very hurt he's starting to take your son
actually looks like the nostalgia critic
give me a few more tights they read
enough of these smelly masses oh dear
God it's reptile ninja turtle good I'll
take the picture
and now we are outside for the rare
breed of bird that actually could stand
the touch of best sunlight on the skin
okay okay you're gonna get whoa tacky
mother outside bum I shall handle this
on God to science to science I'm in hang
on Regan take me take me
I have used science and ingenuity to
defeat all who oppose me okay I'm gonna
do this the dude in the suede we touch
the sword oh okay
the Comic Con nerd a place where you can
get exercise right there signing spoon
for some reason I don't know why do you
really let your hair grow some nothing
ah yeah with you dying it I guess I can
see there we get either way you doing oh
you play Texas Holdem I love that G
Holly
it's a reference to role-playing games
wait wait rolls man you mean where
people dress up in different costumes
and pretend there's someone else do it
we got conquering most nation oh my god
where's your hair going ah I know it's
ready I have an advanced hairstyle for
my age I'm I'm over that need anymore
I'm evolving yeah oh yes waiter can't be
there bigger no I'm a leave in there go
I'm getting checked out in there maybe
see we can get into my did you really
work it and sort of working I had enough
of this delicious bum you're fired
how much do you wanna mess you charged
nothing I'll do it for free wow you have
a smell of cat urine and all you have
everybody here
well typically we're going to take over
this nation and I will rule than iron
fist and all who oppose me will be sent
to obedience domes that I was well but
Alma Rambo and I got no rule to summer
vacation all the time
I don't think I need any one of these
idiots I shall find someone else to help
me go again team up and fight
I'm colored by the you're ready for
precipitate make it have a crowd here
make your prism attend speech if you
have to me I show the man total
obedience my factories building robots
for which I will conquer the rest
Oh
well I think we've completely
brainwashed these pathetic masses I was
brainwashed from Earth indeed so my
conquest of Canada is now complete I am
now your one and true ruler until next
time I shall take over Mexico